[Musique]
je perds la mémoire
parfois je pense à
ce que sera mon tout dernier souvenir avant que
la bougie ne
s'éteigne
[Musique] c'est
mon anniversaire et j'aimerais vraiment
voir la danse c'est ce que tu veux que
pour toi
je ne  Je ne sais pas combien de temps il me reste
avant que les choses n'empirent, alors je me suis assuré
de me souvenir de chaque petit détail gros trois trois trois gros trois
reste immobile
[Musique]
c'est la première fois en 36 ans que tu
prononces les mots
c'est mon frère
[Musique]
je ne m'inquiète pas d'oublier
les gros trucs
ce sont les petites choses que je ne suis pas encore prêt à
abandonner si  tu es perdu tu peux
regarder et tu me trouveras
maintes et maintes fois
si tu tombes je te rattraperai je serai là
où les enfants sont assez vieux pour commencer à
créer des souvenirs des choses importantes dont ils se
souviendront pour le reste de leur
vie
[Musique  ]
jusqu'à la fin de la journée, il y a toujours une
chance que tu te souviennes d'
autre chose, c'est comme ça que nous allons nous en souvenir à
maintes reprises